I've talked a lot about precession and
the changes in the inclination of
Earth's orbit but I haven't told you why
they are happening and I'm not going to
go into the physics of it it's a little
bit beyond this discussion right over
here but they really a byproduct of the
earth and Suns interactions with earth
and with the fact that earth is not a
perfect sphere so if I draw earth so
this is my little drawing of Earth and
let me put the poles over here North
Pole and South Pole it actually turns
out that Earth is fatter than it is
taller so if you were to measure Earth's
or its diameter along the equator its
diameter around along the equator it is
43 kilometers or about 2743 kilometers
which is approximately 27 miles longer
longer than if you were to measure its
diameter from pole to pole so longer
than the pole to pole diameter and the
fact that Earth has this equatorial
bulge that it's not a perfect sphere and
once again I'm not going to go into the
math here it's the interactions between
that I guess you could call it that one
asymmetry of the earth it's that
interaction between that and the the
pull of gravity between the earth and
the Sun and the moon that causes these
long-term cycles these long-term but
this this this this this axial
precession and other other I guess less
noticeable changes in Earth's orbit and
as we'll see in the next video these
aren't the only types of changes in
orbits we have we also have changes in
actual the actual ellipse that Earth's
orbit has actually rotates over time but
that's due more to interactions with
Earth's orbit and the orbit of other
planets in our solar system and once
again it's one of those things that
happen over thousands and thousands of
years so all of these changes there
because earth isn't completely set
symmetrical more fat than it is tall
those interactions between the gravity
of the earth of the Sun and the moon and
Earth's orbit as a whole changes because
of interactions with other objects
inside of our solar system